merci d'être avec nous Mathieu d'Arnaud
nous accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure et lui de l'Ardèche donc du
groupe les républicains on va parler
décentralisation dans quelques instants
puisque vous faites partie du groupe de
travail mise en place par Gérard Larcher
mais d'abord évidemment la réforme des
retraites le gouvernement qui a donc
présenté hier son texte en conseil des
ministres est-ce que c'est un texte que
vous pourriez voter en l'état
je considère qu'aujourd'hui il manque
des choses à mon sens essentielles et
d'ailleurs je suis un peu déçu par les
annonces on nous avait laissé à imaginer
des ajustements qui sont pour moi
majeurs je pense notamment à la question
des seniors je pense notamment la
question des carrières longues c'est
deux sujets sur lesquels on est
particulièrement me concernant je suis
je suis assez déçu
la question et c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est c'est le Ministre de cette égalité
femme homme les femmes étant
désavantagées par cette cette réforme
moi je considère que la réforme des
retraites elle participe pleinement de
notre pacte social et notre système des
retraites est essentiel à préserver nous
en sommes tous convaincus mais faut-il
encore la sortir de décision qui
permettent justement de tendre vers une
forme d'équité et justice sociale
aujourd'hui dans cette région
essentiel essentiel pour qu'on puisse
voter ce texte en tout cas c'est ma
position c'est ce qui fait que
d'ailleurs je m'étais
abstenu lors des propositions du projet
de loi de finance parce que pour moi une
réforme des retraites elle doit être
aboutie quand il manque des dispositions
sur les carrières longues moi je viens
d'un département ou nombre de femmes et
d'hommes ont eu des carrières longues et
aujourd'hui ce sujet des 44 ans
m'interpelle comme la question
aujourd'hui il y a des Français qui
devront cotiser 44 à unités pour
atteindre l'âge de départ même si pour
les carrières longues et en dessous de
64 ans vous dites aucun Français ne
devra cotiser 44 ans je considère que
quand on a une carrière longue et qui
dit carrière longue dit souvent carrière
parfois pénible parce qu'il y a souvent
un cumul des de ces deux de ces deux
paramètres oui à mon sens gouvernement
dit que c'est déjà le cas aujourd'hui
qui a déjà des Français qui sont obligés
de passer mais je pense que c'était le
temps euh et la capacité d'avoir des des
ajustements et puis sur le sujet des
seniors il faut quand même que l'on ait
quelques quelques garanties on entend
que structurellement les choses évoluent
mais on doit je pense
apporter dans cette réforme des
garanties qui aujourd'hui ni sont pas
alors ça veut dire des sanctions sévères
pour les entreprises mais on n'est pas à
des sanctions sévères pour l'instant
l'indique l'index senior c'est tout sauf
des des enfants on aurait pu avoir des
éléments je sais pas si le bonus malus
en fait partie mais il faut qu'il y ait
quand même quelques quelques garanties
c'est pour moi c'est pour moi important
parce que c'est une des modifications
structurelles qu'apporte cette cette
réforme alors je fais confiance au débat
qui auront lieu au Parlement j'y crois
profondément peut-être d'ailleurs à tort
si j'en juge par les déceptions que nous
avons eu notamment à l'occasion du
projet de de loi de finance je pense à
tout ce qui concernait l'accompagnement
des territoires des communes j'espère
qu'il en sera autrement vous écoutera
pas
je note dans l'attitude que on nous
avait
annoncé quelques ajustements quelques
assouplissements quand j'observe ce qui
a été présenté hier oui je suis un peu
déçu est-ce que c'était le bon
calendrier pour présenter cette réforme
clairement non je ne crois pas alors y
a-t-il un bon calendrier c'est la
question qu'on doit qu'on doit se poser
mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui je sais pas
si tous les éléments au regard de la
situation économique sociale c'était le
bon moment pour introduire cette réforme
j'ajouterai un autre paramètre je pense
que c'est un sujet suffisamment
important voire essentiel pour qu'on y
consacre un peu plus de temps pour
permettre à cette réforme d'être un peu
plus abouti qu'elle ne l'est aujourd'hui
on a confondu un peu vitesse et
précipitations je pense que c'est une
réforme qui peut être plus que d'autres
doit faire l'objet d'une large
concertation un peu plus de temps ça
veut dire qu'il aurait fallu attendre
avant de présenter cette réforme ou un
peu plus de temps ça veut dire qu'il il
a fallu utiliser le 47 ans qui limite la
durée des débats au Parlement alors les
deux après
on a souvent dit que les débats
précédents avaient été plus plus courts
moi je pense que le l'actuel majorité ne
doit pas oublier qu'à l'Assemblée
nationale elle ne dispose qu'une
majorité relative ce qui l'oblige et en
l'espèce je pense qu'il lutte était
nécessaire d'avoir un petit peu plus de
temps pour le débat mais aussi pour la
préparation et la présentation de cette
réforme donc il fallait attendre donc à
mon sens il fallait c'était trop tôt et
le 47 ans c'est pas la bonne méthode
puisqu'elle Assemblée nationale il y a
des républiques députés les républicains
qui ont dit qu'il ne voteraient pas ce
texte en l'état contrairement à la ligne
d'Éric Ciotti est-ce qu'il y a de la
place pour les divisions dans votre
partie mais encore une fois je
pense qu'il faut aborder ce texte comme
il doit être abordé je ne sais pas si ça
n'est qu'à faire de groupes politiques
et de et de parties je pense que
d'ailleurs si
on adopte cette cette méthode on ne va
pas suffisamment pour moi rentrer dans
le débat utile pour justement permettre
à cette réforme de prendre en compte ce
qu'elle ne prend pas en compte
aujourd'hui donc moi je pense que chaque
chacune et chacun à ce stade de la
discussion doit pouvoir s'exprimer et
pointer du doigt ce qui manque encore
une fois cette réforme des retraites on
va parler des locaux de la
décentralisation puisque un groupe de
travail dont vous faites partir mise en
place par Gérard Larcher on va faire le
point avec notre journaliste
parlementaire Alex Moussa
[Musique]
bonjour et Alex le président du Sénat
Gérard lacha donc là c'est un groupe de
travail sur la décentralisation suite
aux annonces d'Emmanuel Macron en
septembre dernier on le rappelle la
décentralisation c'est quand l'État
central transfert certaines compétences
aux collectivités territoriales alors il
lieu par le passé des étapes de la
décentralisation par exemple aujourd'hui
la région à la compétence des transports
et la gestion des lycées ou encore le
département à la compétence du
médico-social et la gestion des collèges
et effectivement à l'automne dernier le
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron a indiqué qu'il voulait lancer en
2023 une nouvelle étape de la
décentralisation mais je cite une vraie
décentralisation qui fonctionne écoutez
le président de la République ça marche
si on a
la compétence la responsabilité le
pouvoir normatif et le financement
ensemble et après un peu plus de 5 ans à
la place où je suis je peux vous dire
que dans notre pays aucun de nos
compatriotes pensent qu'une seule
compétence et décentralisée parce que
dès qu'il y a un problème et parfois
même les élus à qui on les a
décentralisés joue ce jeu aux côtés de
nos compatriotes il se retourne vers
l'état et dit c'est lui
et cette annonce elle ravie le président
du Sénat qui a depuis des années en
faveur de la décentralisation mais oui
puisque le Sénat et la chambre du
Parlement qui représente ses
collectivités territoriales et les
sénateurs travaillent depuis des années
pour décentraliser davantage le pouvoir
dans le pays alors à la suite de ces
annonces présidentielles et bien Gérard
Larcher a lancé un groupe de travail du
Sénat sur la décentralisation un groupe
de travail dont vous êtes l'un des
rapporteurs Mathieu Darnault et on sent
que le président du Sénat est très
ambitieux à beaucoup d'attentes
concernant cette nouvelle étape de la
décentralisation on l'écoute or il est
d'écrire ces grandes lois de
décentralisation de liberté locale ce
n'est pas
que d'un texte de répartition nouvelle
de compétences de réorganisation de
l'État ou d'organisation différenciée de
nos territoires dans une République une
et indivisible dont nous avons besoin
c'est plus que cela c'est à une nouvelle
archipsabilité et de la décision que
j'appelle cela s'appelle liberté cela
rompt avec la verticalité il faut en
quelque sorte se refonder il faut oser
tout simplement voilà pour les attentes
de Gérard Larcher alors parmi les axes
de réflexion de ce groupe de travail du
Sénat sur la décentralisation il y a
déjà l'objectif de clarifier les
compétences des collectivités
territoriales par exemple que la région
gère totalement la politique de l'emploi
et pas seulement partiellement ensuite
les sénateurs aimeraient que le préfet
devienne un vrai coordinateur
représentant de l'État dans les
départements qui les mains libres face
aux administrations centrales les
petites collectivités territoriales
doivent aussi avoir davantage de moyens
techniques d'ingénierie pour pouvoir
mener leurs projets et puis il y a
l'épineuse question des finances locales
les sénateurs souhaitent redonner de
l'autonomie fiscale aux collectivités
territoriales après la suppression dans
le premier quinquennat de la taxe
d'habitation et puis à la suppression de
la CVAE axe perçu sur les entreprises
dans ce second quinquennat Matthieu
d'Arnaud est-ce que vous croyez à cette
je cite vraie décentralisation
qu'Emmanuel Macron veut mettre en oeuvre
alors qu'on l'a vu dans le premier
quinquennat ça a pas vraiment été un
président qui décentralise le pouvoir
à défaut de d'y croire nous l'appelons
de nos vœux et je le dis très clairement
puisque nous avons déjà voté des
dispositions très fortes ici au Sénat
donc ce que je dis nous l'avons déjà
fait je suis plus réservé sur la portée
de l'intention du chef de l'État même si
j'espère qu'elle sera
je veux dire qu'elle aboutira à un texte
ambitieux comme cela a été
comme il en a pris l'engagement mais
c'est aussi ça l'objet de ce groupe de
travail c'est de mettre un peu la
pression sur Emmanuel Macron pour le
coup c'est surtout d'être au rendez-vous
d'un texte qui est annoncé pour pour la
fin de l'année je crois vous l'avez dit
dans les exemples nous nous avons
notamment souhaité que s'agissant de la
politique de l'emploi de tout le volet
économie ce soir les régions qui soient
à la manœuvre c'est un exemple très
précis nous souhaitons clairement que
les territoires singulièrement les
territoires ruraux et les moyens de
fonctionner qu'on donne à nos
collectivités départementales communales
intercommunal les moyens d'une
ingénierie pour pouvoir porter des
projets des sujets qui sont très
pratiques moi je crois que la
décentralisation
c'est finalement le levier que nous
n'avons pas suffisamment actionné dans
notre pays et qui permettrait pour moi
de répondre à deux questions déjà la
confiance de nos concitoyens dans leurs
élus par ce lien de proximité je crois
que on peut redorer la confiance dans
les élus dans en faisant en sorte que
nos concitoyens
mesurer la portée de l'action de leurs
élus et quoi de mieux que de renforcer
la proximité et puis le deuxième point
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on observe une
véritable décentralisation
dans les faits et on a besoin aussi
d'observer maintenant une véritable
différentiation les problématiques du
littoral ne sont pas les problématiques
de territoire de montagne on voit bien
qu'il y a besoin d'ajustement et je
crois que c'est notamment ce que nous
appelons de nos vœux par rapport au rôle
des préfets de coordonnées l'action au
niveau local convaincu qu'il y a lieu à
prendre en compte ces points de
différenciation et je crois que ça aussi
c'est quelque chose que nous appelons de
nos vœux c'est un point fort de notre
groupe de travail est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec Emmanuel Macron quand il
dit que on a beau avoir partagé des
compétences avec les collectivités
territoriales par le passé à chaque fois
qu'il y a un problème au final on se
retourne vers l'état
oui alors l'état fait en sorte aussi
qu'on se retourne vers lui je pense que
c'est c'est quelque chose que nous avons
suffisamment pointé du doigt à un moment
donné la décentralisation c'est de c'est
cette volonté de donner aux
collectivités départements région
commune les moyens d'exercer les
compétences qui l'auront été transférées
et pas à chaque fois d'avoir la main
invisible de l'État qui finalement
minorent la portée de du transfert de de
la compétence ce qui doit déboucher
aussi sur une responsabilisation pleine
et entière de nos élus qui auront la
capacité à assumer les compétences qui
leur sont transférées encore une fois
avec une seule finalité c'est de
répondre aux aspirations de nos
concitoyens convaincus encore une fois
que ce qui est vrai en Ardèche n'est pas
vrai dans le Finistère ou dans le
Bas-Rhin que ce qui est vrai sur des
territoires du littoral n'est pas vrai
sur des territoires de montagne donc il
y a besoin de cette ajustement
qui est absolument nécessaire
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il faut aller vers
plus d'autonomie pour certains
territoires certaines collectivités je
pense à l'Alsace notamment
je crois qu'il faudra vraiment
travailler au sein de ce groupe pour
entendre l'ensemble des élus mais le
sujet alsacien à l'évidence fait partie
des sujets sur lesquels on va on va
plancher savoir su aussi la collectivité
de collectivités bretonnes notamment le
Conseil régional de Bretagne qui vont
faire des des propositions je crois que
on est là pour écouter
l'ensemble des territoires pour avoir
parfois des compétences particulières
comme la collectivité européenne
d'Alsace voilà l'idée c'est vraiment
d'être à l'écoute de tous et faire des
propositions qui permettent des
ajustements encore une fois dans le
champ qui est celui de la loi
actuellement il y a une mission
d'information sur les maires et l'avenir
de la commune qui va être créé sur
laquelle vous allez tout
particulièrement travailler quel est
l'objectif l'objectif c'est de pointer
du doigt aujourd'hui une réalité c'est
que les mers sont les élus qui sont
peut-être les plus plébiscités par nos
concitoyens et je crois qu'aujourd'hui
ils n'ont pas réellement sont les moyens
d'exercer leur mandat ou leur mission
que ce soit par l'absence de moyens
financiers par la perte de compétences
donc oui quelque part ils sont un peu
empêchés d'agir nous aspirons à montrer
justement cette réalité et surtout à
trouver des pistes et des solutions qui
encore une fois pourront être évoqués
débattus à l'occasion de ce futur projet
de loi encore une fois nous nous
appelons de nos vœux pour leur permettre
d'avoir plus de moyens pour agir encore
une fois au plus près des besoins de nos
concitoyens sur l'avenir de la commune
puisque ça fera aussi partie de cette
mission d'information est-ce que
l'intercommunalité est une menace pour
l'avenir des communes c'est pas une
menace mais on doit trouver finalement
le juste complément entre
intercommunalité et commune aujourd'hui
trop de maires nous disent finalement
ayant laissé partir l'ensemble de nos
compétences je suis encore la porte
d'entrée de nos concitoyens pour
justement tout ce qui concerne l'action
publique de proximité mais
malheureusement je n'ai pas suffisamment
de capacité à répondre aux attentes et
aux aspirations puisque les conférences
les compétences pardon ont été
transférées à l'intercommunalité donc il
faut trouver ce bon mode de
fonctionnement ce bon Modus opérandit
entre intercommunalité commune est-ce
qu'il faut créer un impôts local nouveau
pour les communes après la suppression
de la taxe d'habitation pour leur
redonner de l'autonomie fiscale c'est ce
à quoi nous réfléchissons nous sommes
convaincus qu'il faut préserver un lien
il ne s'agit pas de d'alourdir la
fiscalité mais il faut qu'il y ait un
lien selon nous entre le citoyen et la
collectivité
à tout à l'heure dans le club évidemment
on va aller voir l'actualité dans votre
département de l'Ardèche Mathieu
d'Arnaud direction Privas on retrouve
leur Puma bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous chef de l'agence de Privas
pour le Dauphiné Libéré et à lire dans
vos pages aujourd'hui lors un dossier
sur les zones blanches en matière de
téléphonie
oui tout à fait le Dauphiné Libéré
s'intéresse aujourd'hui au problème de
téléphonie mobile et fixe en Ardèche on
a beaucoup de zones blanches encore il
faut savoir que le meilleur des quatre
opérateurs téléphonie mobile couvrent
seulement 85 % du département autrement
dit il y a encore 15% du département qui
est dans une zone blanche les reporters
du Dauphiné Libéré sont allés à Prades
dans le sudardais un petit village de
1900 habitants et on ne capte dans ce
village que sous un platane c'est un
gros problème et le maire en parle très
bien dans nos colonnes le la deuxième
problématique que l'on aborde c'est le
problème de la téléphonie fixe puisque
cela repose sur le réseau cuivre qui est
peu ou mal à entretenu par l'opérateur
historique en attendant l'arrivée de la
fibre en fait ce réseau va être remplacé
petit à petit par la fibre sauf qu'en
Ardèche on estime que la fibre sera
accessible à 97% des habitants d'ici
2025 au plus tôt et il y a encore 3% des
habitants pour lesquels on a aucune date
monsieur le sénateur d'Ar pourquoi
est-ce que vous estimez que le
déploiement de la fibre est assez rapide
c'est un enjeu pour le désenclavement de
votre département et qu'en sera-t-il des
3%
. alors c'est un sujet sur lequel on a
beaucoup travaillé avec l'ensemble des
parlementaires ardéchois dont on s'est
saisi il y a maintenant plusieurs années
pour faire le constat d'abord que vous
venez de faire à chaleur fuma pour dire
que le département de l'Ardèche avait
pris trop de retard notamment par
rapport aux investissements qui ont été
faits par le passé par l'opérateur
historique mais qui doit être
aujourd'hui complétée par des moyens
notamment dans le cadre du Plan France
France mobile le département a souhaité
prendre sa part aussi à ce travail je
crois que l'Ardèche doit faire l'objet
d'investissement fort sur la téléphonie
mobile il y a semble-t-il une volonté de
rattrapage des différents opérateurs
nous y veillerons je suis plus inquiet
en revanche sur
le ce qu'on appelle le service universel
convaincu que ce que vous dites est une
réalité avec le déploiement de la fibre
qui a été quelque peu tard mais qui ne
sera pas total et donc ça pose des
questions puisque quand on dit service
universel on entend par là le fait que
chacune et chacun des habitants de notre
département doit pouvoir avoir accès
notamment pour des raisons de sécurité
on a parfois de des services
d'aide ou d'accompagnement à domicile
malheureusement on imagine difficilement
comment tout cela va se traduire si
l'opérateur historique ne met pas les
les moyens pour accompagner ce
déploiement de la fibre sur le sur le
territoire et pour renforcer le service
existant actuellement donc on a saisi
toutes les tous les interlocuteurs
encore une fois avec l'ensemble des
parlementaires avec l'ensemble des élus
du territoire aujourd'hui nous y
veillons c'est peut-être un des sujets
qui nous préoccupe le plus avec la santé
publique dans ce l'accès aux soins dans
ce département voilà nous serons
particulièrement exigeants je crois
qu'on a à de nombreuses reprises ici
interpellées notamment à l'opérateur
historique mais plus encore l'état et le
gouvernement je crois que c'est un sujet
sur lequel il faut se continuer à se
mobiliser pleinement il faut surtout des
résultats on a constaté sur l'entretien
du réseau une petite amélioration il
faut aller beaucoup plus loin
aujourd'hui parce que ce que était
évoqué notamment le fait que dans
certaines communes on ne capte quand
certains points de la commune n'est pas
acceptable aujourd'hui
le président du Département veut faire
travailler les bénéficiaires du RSA
oui exactement Olivier Amrane qui est
président du département de l'Ardèche
depuis un an et demi souhaite que les
bénéficiaires du RSA travaillent 10
heures hebdomadaires dans une
association ou dans une entreprise en
échange de leur allocation est-ce que ça
monsieur d'Arnaud c'est normal je crois
que le président l'a expliqué il
souhaite il a souhaité et
malheureusement département n'a pas été
retenu faire partie de l'expérimentation
qui a été évoquée par le gouvernement
nous regrettons que l'Ardèche n'est pas
pu être retenu je crois que l'aspiration
porté par la majorité et le président du
Département c'est justement et faut
croire que ça répond à un besoin
que ce soit de la part des bénéficiaires
ou que ce soit de la part du du monde
économique de permettre justement à
chacune et à chacun de retrouver la voix
de l'emploi et si j'en juge par la
baisse du nombre de bénéficiaires
conjugués à cette accompagnement par des
acteurs économique c'est plutôt quelque
chose de positif alors je veux surtout
pas qu'on tombe dans la caricature il ne
s'agit pas
d'obliger coûte que coûte il y a bien
sûr cette problématique sociale cette
problématique de l'insertion et celui
qui vous parle je veux dire à deux
parents qui sont des travailleurs
sociaux donc je mesure l'importance de
l'insertion par le travail la dimension
sociale c'est la volonté aussi par le
président du du département et je crois
que c'est quelque chose qui est plutôt
plutôt positif en tout cas les modalités
qui semblent se dessiner vont pour moi
dans le dans le bon sens
une dernière intervention regarde la une
on regarde la une allez on regarde la
une évidemment vous nous en avez parlé
encore la galère pour téléphoner c'est
la question qui est à la une du Dauphiné
Libéré dans son édition de l'Ardèche de
Privas merci beaucoup Laure fuma d'avoir
été avec nous et à très bientôt on
l'espère dans cette émission merci à
vous un dernier mot sur votre partie
Mathieu darnot les républicains puisque
Eric Ciotti ça y est a dévoilé
l'organigramme du parti vaste
organigramme on a envie de dire qui est
déjà contesté notamment par Bruno
Retailleau qui dit que l'équilibre
promis par Éric seety n'a pas été
respecté elle est mal partie cette
présidente érection qui je crois qu'il
faut attendre il va y avoir aujourd'hui
ou dans les jours à venir des
compléments apportés à l'organigramme
mais vous me permettrez de penser que ça
ne doit pas être l'alpha et l'oméga je
crois que aujourd'hui nos concitoyens
nous attendent sur le chant des
propositions nous vivons une période on
a débuté cette émission par parler de la
réforme des retraites par parler du
contexte économique et je crois que nos
concitoyens nous attendent sur ce champ
là je crois que notre famille politique
doit être force de proposition doit
préparer
l'alternance et pour se faire doit être
au travail voilà donc je me préfère me
concentrer pour être audible il faut pas
s'afficher une idée déjà si mais
laissons le temps au temps moi je pense
qu'il faut avoir
la capacité à s'inscrire justement dans
le temps on est à 4 ans et demi des
prochaines échéances c'est long même
très long on sait le temps politique
parfois peut-être un peu trop long et je
crois qu'il y a besoin aujourd'hui de
s'organiser de de travailler encore une
fois d'être au rendez-vous des
prochaines échéances on a trop souvent
succombé au jeu des petites phrases des
égaux je crois qu'aujourd'hui il est
temps de se mettre au travail et les
Français jugeront sur sur nos
propositions sur notre capacité aussi à
incarner
cette alternance merci Mathieu d'Arnaud
merci beaucoup
d'avoir invité pendant cette première
demi-heure dans
secrétaire du Parti socialiste dont la
réélection est contestée en interne il
nous livrera sa réaction sur ce qui se
passe en ce moment même au sein de son
parti mais d'abord on va accueillir
notre prochaine invité c'est